all right character build speed run all right it looks like
me i'm getting my hair color i'm good to go i might need to
look a little bit more healthy wait this this game has lore
i did not know that you mean you have 150 hours on this game
what do you mean i don't know i just thought it was like pew
pew pokemon i don't know all right i'm holding the guild oh
my god bro what's going on here all right where's our base
what are we doing for our base figure it out motherfucker
Where are we building our base?
PP.
I'm making a workbench right here.
Basically, what we're going to do is we're going to work our
way towards where we're going to set up the base and just
catch shit along the way.
If you get lost, just, you know, ask the gods where it is.
Ask the gods.
All right, no problem.
So let me tab out real quick and ask the gods.
Murder is wrong from our pal level, right?
That's a problem.
One of the global events is we have to get 20 humans and put
them in the viewing cage.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wow.
That's neat.
I love that.
of them earlier too.
How many people do we already have?
What do you mean?
We have one people.
We got a second people.
Hopefully we're about to have more people.
Yeah, I will catch people too.
I will get it done.
People catching.
Woo!
This is what we wanted, Nintendo.
This is what we wanted.
I want to catch Professor Oak.
We got another person.
You got another one?
Yeah.
Nice.
Anyway, there's a guy down here in the rock.
If anybody is available and want to catch him, he's like
right here.
I'm heading over.
Don't worry.
My night and shining armor where are you all right you have
to hit him in the head because he doesn't technically have a
hitbox there you go okay yeah i got him no i got him out i
got him out though come on get over here 56 90 oh i got it
you guys you guys need to get thug i know where the wait oh
there's a shiny lampbell that's good that's it don't kill it
don't kill it no we get extra points as well i'm beating him
up right now again what the fuck oh i got it i got shiny
Clip it!
Wait!
Do I have a job history on?
Clip it, chat!
You couldn't see me with Clip it, bro!
Go kill this sweeper!
Go die, Will!
I only have a pickaxe, so I'm not helpful!
No!
Not the babies!
We don't care about the babies!
No!
Oh god, oh god, I might actually die.
Whoa, whoa.
Give me that sweeper!
Go!
I missed!
Clip, Clip!
I got them!
Another boss down!
Let's go!
We're on our way to get pie.
500 we're last place right now we're ready at 500 guys we're
sort of 15th place right now we're 16 teams right guys yeah
we're not last these things we can do it so fucking fast i'm
just saying oh we just got last place apparently oh don't
worry i could speed run all these bosses and then we're
gonna get out of it we'll be fine we'll be fine because All
I need is to catch up.
Oh my god, you're level 10.
I didn't even realize.
Okay.
You kill him?
No, no.
I meant like my wolf is level 10.
Level 10.
Yeah, because I forgot I killed the other one accidentally.
You don't lose your pals when you die.
No, but he died because I drowned him accidentally.
I didn't.
So I had to replace him for a little bit.
Go Fox.
Go.
I don't have a weapon still because I keep...
Whoa!
I'm done.
Whoa, whoa.
He fucking almost one shot me.
Holy shit.
Do you have a shield?
No.
We don't need shields.
Shields are for losers.
I say as I'm about to die.
Yeah.
Can I catch him?
He's definitely dead.
Oh, okay.
Well.
More balls.
Less shields.
That's right.
At least don't get involved.
Come on.
Please.
At least give me that.
I got him!
Cliff it!
Cliff it got Grintel!
I'm dead though, but I got Grintel.
That's all that matters.
I can't.
seem to stay alive.
Whoa, shiny!
He, like, spawned next to me.
I was like, what am I hearing?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, I might die.
No!
Please, please, I'll let you catch you.
Please.
Clip it!
I got him!
That's fine.
I got the fuck.
And I died next to the respawn beacon.
It was worth it.
Oh, look.
I'm gonna go catch her at the quivering right now.
Alright, let's hope I don't die.
Let's go.
Oh, shit.
i'll be fine oh i don't have arrows why do i keep forgetting
to bring arrows trying to catch this man oh no i'm too
strong he's dead oh well oh no this is what it is no what is
our ranking now my chat says that our ranking has not been
updated well to be fair we haven't really been doing any
achievements we've just been like progressing i got
quivering clip clip clip clip the cutest in the game i would
die for that thing chrypha are you done anything that hasn't
been clipped yet uh i mean i've clipped a bunch of stuff but
i haven't submitted I don't know.
Oh, yeah.
What have you not submitted?
I don't know.
I just asked them the clip and then I move on.
What is it?
What did you do?
Fucking, they're in the clips.
I don't know what to tell you, man.
What does it mean?
I'm trying to do as much as I can in the small amount of
time I have.
What is your mission right now?
Fucking killing the bosses.
What do you think, man?
Well, how many bosses have you done?
Fucking like six, seven.
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
Do we even clip seven up straight for his bosses?
They're in the clips.
We need to make sure we got everything.
Woo!
Please.
Oh, clip, clip, clip, clip, I got the...
Clip!
Clip, clip, clip!
Let's go!
I got the bat!
Okay, I can do one more boss, I think.
Okay, I can get the doom mud.
Doom mud, get over here!
The last 10 points right here!
Let's go!
One fucking min-maxing?
Yeah, it was too hard.
It was worth a try.
I wanted those to go-tok-tok-tok-tok-o!
But then I had to use, like, five trazillion balls and one.
Please, please, no.
a lot of balls that is two months i got two months i got two
months nice we got mvp okay how many minutes do i have left
oh one minute okay that's right i got the one we needed all
right here we got the one ten then mod got all of our palace
that we captured chill sweet tumas do mud pen king azuro
grintel broncherry right we got broncherry kimpaka bushi
quivern bell bat Talia, Grand Cherry Aqua, Worsack,
Relaxaaurus.
Is that over them?
We have everything.
Now we die.
Okay, now we're done.
You can start.
Okay, we can start now.
Okay, we can start.
Let's go.
I'm ready to clip this when I defeat this tower.
Shout out to my mods.
Thank you so much for clipping everything yesterday.
You're the realist.
They now have a nickname thanks to Doki.
They're now called the Peepy mods.
Which sounds like something that I feel like the bosses just
aren't like as well.
worth it in this game.
I guess it's like dark so so it's like it's not as rewarding
to kill them.
Yeah.
Van Worm please stop!
Oh my god.
I've Van Worm got stuff.
No, why are you hungry?
You're not allowed to starve.
Stop starving!
I didn't tell you.
Stop building!
Get the fucking butt here!
These fucking pals!
The gold craft balls!
This is not what I paid you for because you're not getting
paid in general.
You're allowed to survive if you make balls.
Yeah.
Earn your food.
Let's go!
Assembly line.
Clip this clip, clip, clip, clip.
Boss eliminated.
Clip, clip.
I'm starving.
I'm on HP.
Something's gonna sneeze.
I'll die.
In that moment, we get raided right there.
No.
Those five berries are for our pals, okay?
They gotta split it between the 14 of them.
Well, now it's too bad.
Now they have zero berries.
Because I'm starving.
Lily's life matters more than the pal.
Exactly.
More easy.
Come on, leave me alone.
Leave me alone.
Oh, shit.
Okay, dude, my dear turn.
You're level 22.
I think you'll be fine.
Actually, no.
You will not be fine.
Oh, shit.
What?
That'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
All right, now.
You stay here.
Oh, my God.
Why is it 8%?
All right, clip, clip, clip.
I got over a dash.
Clip, clip.
We got our first medium bosses.
Let's go.
All right, who's the next boss?
That is a level 38.
I am not high enough level for this.
We don't have a choice.
Trust the process.
Trust the pal.
Trust Lily she is a certified pal I'm a certified pal look
I'm fighting Lily
I don't think I can kill the second tower girl she's way too
strong no oh god I feel like this is the fastest I'm not
gonna go Tower 2!
Let's go!
Clap, clap, clap!
Oh my god, we did it.
Back to work.
Enough standing around.
Work, work, work.
It's time to get back.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Sweep, sweep.
That was fun.
Let's have some more sometime in some time.
Okay, you really do sound like the voice from the game
though.
You can just tell me that you're the guy from...
You know...
I would be a sick voice actor.
Get a voice reel right now and apply.
I don't know how that fucking works.
some voice actors guild or some no i don't think so i use
your clout i'm a voice actor i'm a voice actor done if you
never try you'll never get employed i don't want to try why
not i just want everything to be given to me i got spoken
like a true content creator how to become a voice actor step
one declare intent it's just that easy i can do a kill the
mammores right okay well if you need help and good luck
thank you I really appreciate that if you need to help no
one can go no one can help you but if you need oh this boss
is easy I'm so tanky now or my pals are tanky oh pal go oh
I'm so good dark soulings now leave me alone oh my god
please my mamma I'm just trying to catch my Why is it 5%
this mammores is taking fucking forever?
Oh my god, I think I definitely need a hypersphere some
shit.
What are the mats for hypersphere?
I have, we have all the mats.
I just can't kill them.
Oh, okay.
We need circuit boards to build this.
Oh, so mammores is caught.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
I got it.
Are you guys all ready for dungeon?
Yes.
Okay, I'm just, let's go find the...
Oh, yeah.
Make sure you don't get hit.
Just keep running.
Wait, did you get a wolf finally?
PP.
I forgot to fucking bring it though.
I might die actually.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder.
I am consenting to witnessing a murder right now.
9-1-1, please.
There's a murder happening right now.
Go Pinky.
Go little guy, you got this.
Well, I'm just gonna watch.
I don't have any fucking weapons anymore.
Yay, murder!
Yay!
You gonna catch him?
No.
Clip, clip, clip, clip, clip!
Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip Clip
Clip Clip Clip Cl
Okay, well, we have, like, 30 minutes, so you guys, like,
let's try to speedrun this.
Sureforn and I can finish the rest of the bosses.
We need to be at level 20 as well to make the zoo with 20
people in it.
Yeah, all right.
Trevor, do you want to do the black marketeers right now
with me?
I found the black marketeer, level 40.
Let's go.
We gotta capture him.
Oh, my God.
Oh, he's getting fucked up.
Yeah, he's getting fucked up.
Nice.
12%er.
Let's go.
We got one of the black marketeers.
We just need one more clip that clip clip clip us catching
that woman and then get it later Base level 20 all right
viewing cage, but we also need you to put your humans.
I'm putting humans How do I put the humans in yeah, you walk
up to it and hit X?
Okay How many do they need okay.
I'm putting more than three they're all gonna be in there
clip clip clip clip clip clip viewing cage Like two more.
You need to be backed by three minutes if you can so we can
do the chickpea.
I'm getting the butcher knives.
We have to do it all at the same time.
I think so.
We shall get together then.
We need to do this fast because I need to go get my shit.
Let me know what you guys are already.
How do I cleave them?
Put in your inventory.
Wait, I have it in my inventory, but I don't have a butcher
option.
Yeah, hold it.
Hold it.
Wait, hold it.
I can't hold it.
Wait.
Time is of this.
Guys!
I need to get level 50.
Put it on the weapon slot.
What do you mean?
You just drag it there.
Take away one of your items.
You guys are bugged.
You guys might not have to re-log.
You have to re-log.
Just re-log.
There's no other way to explain it other than just put it in
your weapon slot.
That's the only way we can win.
That's literally all you do.
What do you mean?
You're picked at?
You're literally bugged.
You have to re-log.
I just re-logged.
And now I can't put it in my weapon slot.
Yeah, just re-log.
I still haven't re-logged.
What do you mean?
Put it in your weapon slot.
No shot.
Okay, wait, I've got it.
It's there.
It's not worth it anymore.
I got it.
I'm trying to put the chicken in my fucking weapon slot.
No fucking way you're thinking that, friend.
I go downstairs and butcher this fucking chicken.
I'm downstairs.
Let's go.
All right.
Butcher.
Clip, clip, clip, clip.
Clip, clip.
Got it.
We got it.
right there you have one minute to get to level 50.
how do i get to level 50.
what can you do in one minute or 30 seconds i can kill a
boss okay i don't think we can get that in 30 seconds like
ding ding ding you're statue you're statue you're statue you
know what though we did we did we did pretty well we did
pretty good we did pretty good we could almost got 120 man
we almost got
That was, like, the most stressful last five minutes.
Holy shit.
Top three, guys.
I can't believe it, everyone.
Top fucking three.
Plus one.
Holy shit, that was so fun.
When we started, I still can't believe it, the last three
minutes.
We were just screaming at each other.
We were just like, guys.
I hope you guys had a great time with us today.
happy with my team with pp chad lily and sure for it was a
great team so thank you everybody i'm gonna call it here
i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye